"Meet the P
that's going to take your V."
We were just starting
to think about producing things,
and Ryan's book was coming out.
I read the book
and we took a meeting with Ryan
and then we started working together.
I have a thing.
It's called cerebral palsy.
What's that?
It's a disability resulting from
damage to the brain
before, during, or shortly after birth.
And it's outwardly manifested through
muscular incoordination.
Special was based on my book,
which was based on my life.
It's basically about my experience
being gay and disabled,
being marginalized in society,
and the things you do to kind of get by.
It's got substance to it,
it's got meat to it.
I think one of the most
challenging things about Special
is actually fitting everything
into this little nugget of goodness.
There's so much funny,
there's so much story,
there's so many incredible characters.
Mommy, he's walking funny.
It's because I was hit by a car!
Ryan's kind of a classic underdog.
He just, like, wants a job,
wants a healthy relationship with his mom,
wants a boyfriend.
But there are a million obstacles
kind of preventing him
from getting those things.
Hi. New girl. I'm Kim.
So, the personality of Kim,
I wanted someone
that really, like, snap, crackle, popped,
and was just comfortable
in her own skin.
Everything that Ryan wasn't.
Like, at first glance,
it looks like Kim has her shit together,
and she's his sherpa.
But I think she learns
just as much from him.
They understand what it's like to feel
like you're a fish out of water.
It's really easy to laugh
or cry along with them
because it's not hard
to put yourself in their shoes.
Take off all your clothes and tell me
everything you love about your body.
-That's a pass.
-Come on. I love my boobs.
And my nipples have
a very strong female POV,
like, they could basically have
their own Netflix special.
I think by the time we meet Karen,
there's smoke coming out of the hood.
It's fixed.
Karen's never thought about
what she wants for one second
because it's always been about
Ryan, Ryan, Ryan.
And I think that she's comforted by that.
This is actually a codependent
relationship that has to be codependent.
She ties your shoelaces, she feeds you.
That's a really valuable
aspect of their dynamic,
and actually having to
walk away from each other
when there is still a lot
that you need from me.
And I do walk away from you
and it takes a lot.
-You do walk away.
-I do.
When we first started
working with Ryan on adapting his book
for some sort of screen version of it,
none of us thought
that Ryan would be in it.
We were not pitching myself as the star.
And we did that because I wasn't an actor,
I was a writer.
But, like, I really loved acting.
The camera loves that guy's face.
And his eyes and his glasses,
and you just want to hug him.
Every actor wanted to tell this story.
They all just fit
like a beautiful jigsaw puzzle.
The issues that we're dealing with
are mature issues,
and there's something really beautiful
and profound in that.
And it normalizes a lot of things
that I think aren't normalized on TV:
a disabled person dating and having sex,
a curvier girl being confident
in a bathing suit,
older, new love.
-I don't know what you're talking about.
-Who is older?
-Did she say a word?
-Wow.
I just hope everybody just enjoys
watching it as much as I do.
And enjoys watching Ryan
act out this journey.
Because it's really great.